الحج كان قديما رحله محفوفه بالمخاطر حتى
انه كان يقال ان الذاهب للحج مفقود
والعائد منه مولود مثل يجسد واقع الصعاب
التي يعانيها الحاج في ازمنه مضت في رحلته
التي تمتد لاشهر عده عبر طرق وعره
لكن الحاله تبدل فمنذ بدايه عهد الدوله
السعوديه اصبحت رحله الحج اكثر يسرا
وسهوله عبر مر السنوات فمن مشى على
الاقدام او حتى من جاء مستظلا بشراء بدائي
في البحر واخر ركب على ظهر الابل في البر
كلهم امام طرق وعره هي الان اصبحت جزءا من
الماضي وحل محلها اكثر وسائل النقل تقدما
وتطورا في العالم لكن هذا حتى الوصول اما
بعده واثناء اداء المناسك وفرت السعوديه
خدمات خاصه متطوره لخدمه الحجيج منها
منظومه النقل والخدمات اللوجستيه من بينها
قطار المشاعر المقدسه وقطار الحرمين
مما يقدر ب 1490 متر مربع في عصر ما قبل
الاسلام والعصر النبوي وصولا الى 193 الف
متر مربع هي مساحه عماره المسجد الحرام
بعد التوسعات التي مر بها المسجد الحرام
خلال كل هذه السنوات والتي كان اخر
مشاريعها تدشين الملك سلمان خمسه مشاريع
رئيسيه ضمن المشروع الشامل للتوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه
خدمات متطوره عاما بعد عام شهدتها منظومه
الحج قسمت بمضاعفه اعداد الحجاج حتى وصلت
الى ارقام مليونيه منها برنامج خدمه
الضيوف الرحمن الذي يعد احد برامج تحقيق
رؤيه السعوديه 2030 بهدف رفع مستوى
الخدمات المقدمه لهم واثراء تجربتهم
الدينيه والثقافيه
مبادرات مختلفه بعضها في المشاعر والاخر
في بلدان الحجاج انفسهم على سبيل المثال
مبادره طريق مكه وتاشيره الالكترونيه
للحجاج والمعتمرين وغيرها الكثير
[موسيقى]
وبعد ان عصفت جائحه كورونا بالعالم اعلنت
السعوديه في يناير من العام الحالي عن
عوده اعداد الحجاج الى ما كانت عليه قبل
الجائحه لاتاحه اداء الحج امام اكبر عدد
من المسلمين حول العالم خدمات متكامله
قدمت السعوديه عبر سنوات كانت خلف وصول
اعداد الحجاج منذ 54 عاما الى اكثر من 99
مليون حاج